oh
[Musique]
et
sont toutes petites capsules qui vont
venir s'intégrer dans les maillages du
tissu pour être complètement fixé
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut avoir un effet à
très long terme
en fait on peut laver le mcg 20 x 60
degrés et on a toujours la même
efficacité
c'est à dire 100 % dans têtu news
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sas prêts préventifs suivant
l'environnement dans lequel on évolue
dans une journée que ceux sur les
transports en commun quand on fait les
courses cantonné au bureau ou ailleurs
on va utiliser ce spray à plusieurs
reprises dans la journée matin midi et
soir et peut-être plus sur son
environnement favorable à une
contamination ou non et on va venir tout
de suite immédiatement si le virus
rentrer dans les narines et d'en face à
vannes qui est la principale pour de
l'entrée on va de désactiver très
rapidement dans la journée
[Musique]
oh
on
à
et
ça libère et opérationnelles déjà depuis
donc cet été et il est utilisé dans
différents types de lieux dans par
exemple en vendée dans les ehpad les
dentistes en auvergne rhône-alpes
on a des centres
handicapé en temps de belgique et les
aéroports depuis ont été les premiers en
particulier des accords internationaux
djibouti et de brazzaville qui l'ont mis
en oeuvre et qui continuent à l'utiliser
[Musique]
on a monté tout ça en huit mois on a
très vite trouvé des mots comme enfin
quand je dis très vite c'est dans l'été
voilà
on est arrivé sur un local qui était
dans un état voilà et il a fallu faire
en remettent au goût du jour
et donc on nous produisons des masses
d'ores et déjà depuis quelques dix jours
maintenant
[Musique]